oh hey see good news Oh Elsa I don't
care why are you calling mom Elsa your
Clayton uniform came today it is
adorable
it just looks smart what you think of
the roast I tried a new prepackaged
spice mix cheater for most mammalian
species survival depends on knowing and
sticking with your pack stop sitting on
me like an egg I'm not an egg but the
members of my pack keep migrating to
other schools I hate it there just give
it a chance hey I'm Casey don't care two
other houses you threw a grenade into
our lives I can't be around you or just
away from me it's a mystery what was
once something that seems so rock solid
it cracks wide open before you know it
you are so deep it's impossible to dig
yourself back out if anyone find it
difficult to deal with change but
there's always a way out
I know it's gonna be difficult but you
can handle it he hasn't applied to any
colleges I have no idea what I should do
you have to start making decisions for
yourself what do you want to do
everybody has setbacks oh you can't let
em bring you down would it be this out
okay
I used my discount to get you these
pencils for school you don't have to do
that I'll be a big brother I can take
care of you sometimes too
they must look like terrible parents
really you seem like people
it's a rough world out there that's why
you need your family
I like that we're secure enough to do
this semi-regularly I'm neutral about it
[Music]
you